we're going to begin this hour with our
series we call it a more perfect union
which aims to show that what unites us
As Americans is far far greater than
what divides US Today's story proves the
old saying home is where the heart is
the rising costs of seemingly everything
has created an even bigger divide
between what people can afford the woman
behind one Innovative non-profit are
working to help by keeping usable items
out of landfills while filling the homes
of those in need with furniture and best
of all hope CBS News special
correspondent James Brown is here he's
in studio with a story that's close to
his heart James always good to see you
especially when you bring your heart
along and that I do Gail Tony and Nate
good to see you guys as well you know
what I want to tell you about a woman in
Suburban Maryland who for a long time
has been motivated to action to bridge
the gap between the wealthy and the poor
and as you mentioned using Furniture as
the means now the young lady that you're
about to meet says her life changed
because of furnished Hope DC
I got tired of running running from
violence
the struggle this was my last hope hope
was all homeless mom Gloria Anton had
moving her three children to a new city
with nothing got to the point where I
slept in my car for maybe three four
days and your kids they was with me you
and your three kids in a car
until they got this apartment
watch your kids oh my God coming home
for their first time not to a hotel room
or a shelter but their own place all
furnished for free by the Washington
non-profit furnish hope D.C they came
with a whole box truck and stayed the
entire day when the kids got home they
was like wow
tell me how that impacted you to see
them happy
I just smile
furnish hope even filled her freezer we
discussed what was my needs and I just
say hey everything it really bothered me
that she had nothing and had no one to
turn to because children deserve the
bare necessities if anything Adrian
Herbert helps furnish hope D.C meet the
need you're a mother I am and when you
heard those kids scream
oh I melted
I cried because it made me think of my
own children and some of the obstacles
we've been through Herbert and her five
kids live in public housing but she
spends her days here I'm here to support
you helping others with long-time
Community volunteer Nikki mock who
founded furnish hope mock often in her
own pickup picks up gently used
furniture
and hauls it here where the need is
greatest Deanna Campbell and her six
kids lived for seven months in this
Empty Apartment we like we sit on the
floor
so furnished hope filled her home and
her heart we could have family time
comfortably like sitting hugging each
other on the couches
often in sight of the U.S Capitol the
neighborhood's furnished hope serve can
feel a world away in the DMV area
that's going to be a client even during
our interview you know it's another
thing
Darnell
the need kept knocking on Furnish Hope's
Door there is enough for everyone to
have a comfortable home you really
believe that I know that for a fact on
my way here today around the corner from
me there is a beautiful queen mattress
sitting out with the garbage
you know me I had to stop I went and
knocked on the door I asked if we could
I asked if we could put it aside do you
know this neighbor yeah I do oh so they
didn't think you were crazy coming they
did but I do know the neighbor
I hopped in with mock you've made this
kind of run how many times
250. and she brought a bed to this
family that lost everything in an
apartment fire and it cost us zero you
know it was free and while their
neighborhood is nearly 95 percent
African-American Tanya silver and her
son William just see someone here to
help makes no difference what color she
is no no issues there at all nope none
and those who might have an issue with
her heart wanting to help you would say
that's their issue she does it from her
heart mock admits her heart has skipped
a few beats that's her Bullet Hole
they're just novel is in the car they
were just trying to scare me it didn't
work she kept up the deliveries it then
it was on the street I go hey do you
want to make ten dollars by any chance I
need help getting this furniture in it's
really going for a good cut I've never
not been able to have help
and remember Gloria who was homeless
just this summer now she volunteers with
furnish hope helping others even though
you're just getting the footing yourself
right you're excited about helping
others to get the footing that you now
have yes and you're enjoying it yes
punish Hope plays a big part especially
the hope and that's what these women who
furnish Hope by the truckload hold on to
I hope we're going to be around for a
long time I will thank you
yeah well Nikki yeah we have to because
we're needed
[Music]
and as I got to see firsthand the need
clearly is overwhelming but you know
furnish hope D.C relies entirely on
donations and the furniture that people
give the task clearly is more than
daunting but Nikki and Adrian know the
need can be met and as you heard her say
that children deserve the basic
necessities donations but also clearly
hustle they're picking up stuff they see
and also these volunteers they're helped
and then right away they're helping
again isn't that the nicest thing to
know the people that were helped now
they're giving back I heard meal comment
about that that's what's so important as
well I love the name of the organization
furnished hope too because that's
exactly what they're doing because Gail
to hear the kids when they went to
school to hear from other kids saying I
understand you guys are poor because you
have no furniture they were sleeping on
the floor so when it came home and saw
the house looking like that it was like
oh my gosh and now they're doing better
in school because they have of course
the basic necessity you mentioned the
word Necessities those kids were blown
away by the furniture but they started
screaming when they were looking under
the sink yeah so you know what's under
the sink cleaning products normally it's
not something that's very exciting
they've never seen yeah and you know I
guess the dad over here and I guess he's
you're the same they were thinking about
maybe a hiding place or something maybe
when they get to have some fun I have no
idea well JB we appreciate you I'll see
you in a couple of days yes sir how come
nobody talks football with you here on
the set we do oh
no we'll talk about Tony all right I
don't know but we were talking about
Zach Wilson and the Jets just earlier I
was going to say the bills to be honest
okay
I was going to say the bills but I
didn't want to pick anybody publicly I
hear you so thank you for asking